foreign
we could say many bad things about
Russia but they have one very good thing
that must be recognized if the golden
rule of any casino is the dealer always
wins in the energy game it is Russia
that always wins it is by far the
largest country in the world and what's
more its territory is full of Natural
Resources which gives it a huge
competitive Advantage just think of the
world's fourth largest economy Germany a
lot of Volkswagens and a lot of Siemens
but for decades Germany has depended on
Russian gas for abundant and cheap
energy as you know all this blew up with
the Russian invasion of Ukraine and not
surprisingly it has been very difficult
to find Alternatives one of the biggest
problems is Germany's reluctance to use
nuclear power last April they shut down
their last three nuclear power plants
and of course there are many experts who
stress that this was a mistake that
nuclear energy could be an alternative
to natural gas and a way to completely
avoid dependence on Russia but wait a
minute because we are talking about
energy and in this game you know what we
said Russia always wins
with 37 reactors Russia is not only the
country in the world fourth on the list
for the most nuclear reactors it also
dominates the nuclear fuel Market you
see although its uranium mines account
for barely five percent of the planet's
production rosatom's Global share in the
uranium conversion process Rises to 27
and soars to 46 in terms of uranium
enrichment capacity this explains as we
told you here on visualpolitik last
February why the West does not impose
sanctions on Russia's state-owned atomic
energy corporation now just as LNG has
offered the major alternative to Russian
gas with nuclear fuel there is another
alternative which is France a country
that has a long nuclear tradition and
could be an important option for the
West to consider if it seeks to reduce
dependence on Russia in Paris they are
clear about their strategy they want to
proceed but they have some stumbling
blocks to get past the main one is that
the French nuclear sector has been in a
permanent crisis for 15 years when it
puts out one fire it immediately starts
another and the latest one has been in a
place as far away as it was unexpected
Niger coup Sparks concerns about French
EU uranium dependency Niger was the last
democracy in the Sahel president bazzoon
was considered by France as an important
Ally in combating the rise of jihadism
in the region now all indications are
that things could change completely with
the new military Junta in Niger the
military constantly reproaches France
for its abuses as a former colonial
power and accuses France of meddling in
its Internal Affairs so the question is
what does what is happening in Niger
have to do with the French strategy to
dominate the nuclear fuel Market what
does this strategy consist of is the
West going to continue buying enriched
uranium from Russia Today on
visualpolitik we're going to answer
these questions but first did you have a
clue that the cost of certain online
products and services can fluctuate
based on where you're hanging out on the
globe travel firms like Airlines and
hotels adjust prices based on the user's
country therefore if you're in an area
with higher buying power than your
desired spot be on guard a UK study by
nordvpn showed prices can double
especially for vehicle rentals so how do
you sidestep these price disparities
nordvpn our sponsor today masks your
location letting you choose another this
allows you to find the best deals for
your getaway furthermore nordvpn gives
you the chance to soak up unlimited
content from a diverse parts of the
world without any geographical barriers
it's compatible with a multitude of
devices and allows you to link up to six
of them with a single account on top of
that nordvpn's threat protection feature
will have your back operating in the
background even when you're not hooked
up to a VPN server so quit stalling
check out nordvpn and get four months
extra on a two-year plan by going to
nordvpn.com forward slash vpen and if it
doesn't quite hit the mark for you no
worries they've got a 30-day money-back
guarantee
[Music]
uranium from the colonies
50 years ago the famous oil crisis
occurred the price of dinosaur juice
multiplied by four after the Arab
countries decided to reduce their
production at that time most of the
electricity in France a country with no
oil fields of its own was generated by
oil-fired power plants compared to five
percent provided by the first generation
of nuclear reactors visualpolitik
viewers this crisis was key to the
activation of the Mesmer plan in 1974
Pierre Messmer president pompadu's prime
minister presented to the plan by which
France would end its total energy
dependence on foreign oil his goal was
nothing less than to build dozens of
nuclear reactors all it needed was
uranium for its nuclear Fuel and the
French atomic energy commission already
knew where to find it Samir and kominac
have for decades been two of the largest
uranium mines in the world France
discovered uranium in Niger in 1957. so
when this African country gained its
independence in 1960 Paris ensured that
it maintained Priority Access to niger's
Natural Resources is by means of a
treaty and so the large-scale
exploitation of these uranium mines
started between the end of the 1960s and
the 1970s there some French leaders were
able to deploy all the bad practices
they had already used in Gabon
[Music]
you see France began operating the
munano uranium mine in Gabon in 1960. in
the late 1960s measurements recorded
high levels of gamma and Alpha radiation
among Mine Workers adopting the
radiation protection protocols used in
France required costly Investments and
the French were not in the mood the
solution adopted was much more cost
effective tripling the thresholds above
which radiation exposure was considered
dangerous to human health
this is one of the advantages that the
mines in the former colonies had for
France their costs were much lower
because neither the safety nor the wages
of the miners were the same as in other
countries and at this point I am sure
that someone will be thinking well if
uranium mining has polluted a lot at
least it will have left Niger with an
economic benefit well no the
exploitation agreements were abusively
advantageous for France for many decades
French mining companies paid only 5.5 of
their revenues in taxes to Niger in
Canada and Kazakhstan where orano has
been producing uranium since the late
1990s royalty rates are 13 and 18.5
respectively this has led to disparities
as you can see in this graph between the
amount of uranium produced and the
revenue each country receives in return
in 2014 a new agreement was negotiated
between Niger and orano then called
ariva the royalty rate was raised from
5.5 percent to a figure around 12
provided certain conditions of
profitability and uranium price were
were met conditions have improved
slightly but France has continued to
operate in Niger with a certain
advantage over the international market
if we add to this the fact that Niger is
one of the poorest countries in the
world we can surely speak of yet another
case of the resource curse this is what
economists call it when they refer to a
state that does not benefit financially
from the sale of its resources even so
there is no greater curse than the
corruption of its leaders
in 1974 Lieutenant Colonel saney cooch
staged a coup de tar president until
1987. kunch claimed to receive directly
part of the production of uranium oxide
in a percentage equal to the
participation of the state of Niger in
the Nigerian subsidiaries of the French
mining companies a percentage of more
than 30 percent in this way kunche kunch
wanted to sell the Uranium on his own
account on the international market the
atomic intentions of his customers were
not exactly peaceful Saddam Hussein's
Iraq Gaddafi's Libya Pakistan kunche or
kunj is credited with the phrase we will
sell uranium even to the devil if
necessary now I know what you're
thinking since the military Junta that
has seized power in Niger is out for
revenge against France they will surely
break the agreements for the
exploitation of their minds expel orano
from the country and France will lose
all the uranium in Niger and of course
considering that nuclear power plants
generate about 70 of France's
electricity if niger's military suddenly
cut off the supply of uranium France is
energy production would surely tremble
right well no unlike Germany with
Russian gas this time France has done
its homework and done it very well
France has been able to diversify its
uranium Supply according to data from
the last 10 years the 88 200 tons of
natural uranium imported by France came
mainly from three countries Kazakhstan
27 Niger 20 and Uzbekistan 19 imports
from Australia and Namibia also stand
out with 14 in each case in terms of
annual data uranium from Niger never
accounted for more than 35 of French
Imports in a single fiscal year
[Music]
these data are similar to those of irano
in 2012 niger's Minds provided
two-thirds of its Global Production
however Niger now provides less than
one-third after the common act mine
closed in 2021. all this means that
niger's uranium once decisive is now of
relative importance to the French Energy
System accounting for barely 20 of the
uranium they import compare that to the
60 that Russian gas meant for Germany or
even the 90 that it meant for Eastern
European countries like the Czech
Republic in other words if Niger cuts
off the uranium tap France could easily
replace it with imports from other
countries now that is not to say that
the disruption would have no effect it
would be a setback for its strategy of
being an alternative to Russia in the
nuclear fuel Market what am I talking
about stay tuned
foreign
dominated by Russia
just as combined cycle power plants use
natural gas as fuel to generate
electricity nuclear power plants need
their own fuel the process most commonly
used in atomic power plants to generate
energy is nuclear efficient for this
they need an element that is fissile or
easily split this is where uranium comes
into play now just as you have to refine
petroleum to obtain fuels such as
gasoline or diesel you have to enrich
uranium to be able to use it as fuel in
nuclear power plants the process is the
same as the one used to develop atomic
bombs what changes is the level of
enrichment needed take a look
natural uranium as extracted from the
mines is composed of 99.3 percent
non-fissile
uranium-238 Isotopes the fissile part
uranium-235 Isotopes account for only
0.7 enriched between 3 and 5 this
uranium serves as nuclear fuel for power
plants that generate electricity up to
20 enriched uranium is used to produce
medical Isotopes which are used in
particular in the diagnosis of certain
cancers finally to make a bomb
enrichment must be brought up to 90
percent
and guess what right here is the key
that has led to the international
nuclear fuel Market being dominated by
Russia traditionally uranium has been
enriched by two methods the West opted
for the simpler one gaseous diffusion
nevertheless this simpler method was
very expensive since it requires a lot
of energy to enrich the uranium how much
energy are we talking about well to give
you an idea the enrichment plants that
France opened at the end of the 1970s
consumed 15 terawatt hours per year the
same amount of electricity that would be
used today for public Lighting in Paris
for a century
thank you during the three decades it
was in operation the Georgie's busy
uranium enrichment plant was France's
largest consumer of electricity it
devoured about four percent of France's
entire electricity production in fact at
the height of the Cold War about seven
percent of total U.S electricity
generation was devoted to uranium
enrichment for both military and
civilian purposes
gaseous diffusion was the method used by
the West now what were they doing on the
other side of the Iron Curtain well the
Soviet nuclear program is known to all
both in terms of armament and atomic
energy the USSR started up some 30
reactors as for Uranium enrichment the
Soviet Union opted for a more complex
technique centrifugation however this
method consumes 50 times less energy
than gaseous diffusion this explains how
today in the middle of 2023 we find new
stories like this who in still sending
us nearly 1 billion dollars in nuclear
fuel when the Soviet Union fell in 1991
the United States and the new Russia
agreed to what is popularly known as the
Megaton to megawatt program
highly enriched uranium from former
Soviet nuclear warheads was converted
into low enriched uranium and shipped to
the United States for use in civilian
plants also given the cost differential
Western Electric utilities rushed to
acquire russian-enriched uranium in
doing so they benefited from the more
cost competitive technology of the
Soviet era the problem is that at the
same time they contributed to the ruin
of those facilities in the west that
were still using gaseous diffusion but
of course in those happy 1990s the only
thing in danger of running out under
Boris Yeltsin was our alcohol reserves
so Russia achieved a position of market
dominance that has greatly benefited
rosaton the state Corporation created in
2007 by Vladimir Putin to be the Russian
Giant in the global nuclear energy
Market a giant that is absolutely
Untouchable even under the most adverse
conditions pressure mounts on EU to
sanction Rosa Tom in next Russia
sanctions package neither Brussels nor
Washington has dared to sanction
rossitom's nuclear fuel the United
States stopped enriching uranium years
ago and about a third of the nuclear
fuel it currently uses is imported from
Russia the world's largest and also the
cheapest producer and yet the bill Rises
each year to nearly 1 billion dollars so
in the midst of the war in Ukraine with
sanctions on oil on natural gas and on
thousands of Russian companies and
products it would be ideal not to depend
on the Kremlin for nuclear fuel right
well this is where France's strategy
comes into play
[Music]
the nuclear Epoch
visual politic Community if you are
watching this video from Germany or
Spain you may be surprised but nuclear
is all the rage currently 59 nuclear
reactors are being built in the world
these numbers are scheduled to increase
by another 111 in the next few years in
addition there are plans for another 321
40 of these reactors are or will be
located in China but other powers such
as Russia and India are also investing
heavily in nuclear power even in the
United States there are serious plans to
relaunch this industry and hold on a
moment because in Europe there are
countries that do not want to be left
behind France already announced before
the war in Ukraine that it would build
six new reactors but beside those the
United Kingdom Poland the Netherlands
Slovenia Slovakia the Czech Republic
Hungary Bulgaria Romania Estonia and
Lithuania also have nuclear power among
their plans and it is possible that more
countries will join after the backing
given by the European Union to this
technology
EU Parliament backs labeling gas and
nuclear Investments as green the energy
transition and the fight against climate
change will require investment in new
technologies also in everything that
involves maintaining our quality of life
while reducing greenhouse gas emissions
it is in this area that Brussels has
decided that Renewables and nuclear must
go hand in hand what's more the new
modular reactors are completely changing
the reality of this industry they
require much less investment and can be
built much faster for these reasons
European countries are ready to give
atomic energy another chance they plan
to build new power plants and of course
the most important thing will be needed
nuclear fuel
[Music]
it won't be necessary to increase
uranium production in the mines yes but
also to increase the capacity to process
that uranium convert it and enrich it
and this is exactly where France wants
to play a leading role it is already
working on it as reflected in news
headlines such as this France Maul's new
uranium plant to cut West's Reliance on
Russia according to an irano spokesman
the French state-owned company is
considering two options on the one hand
building a uranium enrichment plant in
the United States on the other hand an
option that would be the quickest and
most likely expanding by 50 the capacity
of its modern George's Bessie 2 plant
operational since 2011 and already
enriching uranium using the centrifuge
technique enriched uranium is measured
in swu separative work units at its
George's Bessie 2 plant France enriches
7.5 million swu per year increasing it
by 50 would raise its capacity to 11
million whereas French nuclear power
plants currently need about 6.5 million
swu this corresponds to the
approximately 8 000 tons of natural
uranium that France needs for its
nuclear power plants if it plans to
produce 11 million swu it will need to
import more than 13 000 tons of uranium
each year and this is where Niger could
create a problem for France
as I was telling you earlier its own
Energy System can afford to do without
the nearly 2 000 tons it Imports every
year from Niger it would find other
suppliers but France does need this
uranium for its strategy of becoming a
major exporter of nuclear Fuel and a
real alternative to Russian domination
in any case there is no doubt that
macron is working in this direction and
that explains news items like this
uranium from Mongolia interests France
macron and his foreign minister have
visited Mongolia in recent months there
they have shown interest in making
Investments worth about 1 billion euros
to get hold of mongolia's uranium as
well as other metals such as lithium of
course in Ulan Batar they have jumped at
the opportunity and have welcomed macron
with open arms they even say that France
is the third neighbor of Mongolia that
giant country wedged like a sandwich
between Russia and China you know that
one along these lines a major agreement
is expected very soon of course this
does not detract from the fact that for
a moment France has a major headache
with Niger don't forget that the power
that is becoming strong in the Sahel is
Russia which could suddenly find itself
in Niger with a new uranium supplier
something that would undoubtedly
contribute to further consolidate its
position of dominance over the nuclear
fuel market and this means that if the
world continues to bet on atomic energy
we will all including the West increase
our dependence on Russia thus increasing
the power of Putin and the Kremlin that
at least seems to be moscow's idea but
now the questions are over to you do you
think France will succeed in its
strategy or will Russia always win in
the energy game you can leave me your
answers in the comments in the meantime
don't forget that we release new videos
every week so please subscribe to
visualpolitik so you don't miss any of
our updates if you like the video please
like it I'll see you in the next one all
the best see you soon
[Music]